probably another surprise to you but I
don't like to be in a hospital or go to
a hospital do you I'm sure many of you
feel the same way right but why why is
it that we hate hospitals so much or is
it just a fact of life we have to live
with is it the crappy food is it the
expensive parking is it the intense
smell or is it the fear of the unknown
well it's all of that and it's more
patients often have to travel long
distances to get to their nearest
hospital right and access to hospital
care is becoming more and more an issue
in rural areas in the US but also in
sparsely populated countries like Sweden
and even when hospitals are more
abundant typically the poor and the
elderly have trouble getting care
because they lack transportation that is
convenient and affordable to them and
many people are avoiding hospital care
altogether and they miss getting proper
treatment due to cost we see that 64% of
the Americans are avoiding care due to
cost and even we do get treatment
hospitals often make us sicker medical
errors are reported to be the third
cause of death in the u.s. just behind
cancer and heart disease third cause of
death I'm in healthcare for over 20
years now and a witness every day on how
broken and are obsolete our hospital
system is let me give you two examples
for in 10 Japanese medical doctors and
five in 10 American medical doctors are
burned out in my home country the
Netherlands only 17 million people live
there we're short a hundred and twenty
five thousand nurses over the coming
years
but how do you even end up here right in
this idea of placing all kind of sick
people together in one big building well
we have to go back to the ancient Greeks
400 BC temples for cure were erected for
people who could go together diagnosis
their treatment and their healing and
then really about 2000 years we've seen
religious care centres all the way up to
the Industrial Revolution where we've
seen hospitals being set up as assembly
lines based on the principles of the
Industrial Revolution to produce
efficiently and get the products a
patient in this case out of the hospital
as soon as possible over the last
century we've seen a lot of interesting
innovations we figured out how to make
insulin we invented pacemakers and x-ray
and we even came into this wonderful new
area of cell and gene therapies but the
biggest change to fix our hospital
system altogether is still ahead of us
right and I believe it's time now we
have the opportunity to revolutionize
the system altogether and forget about
our current hospital system I believe
it's time to create a new system that
revolves around health care and home
recent research has shown that 46
percent of hospital care can move to the
patient's home that's a lot and that's
mainly for those patients who suffer
from chronic diseases and with that
hospitals can shoot reduce to smaller
agile and mobile care centers focus on
acute care all right so things like near
the tourgee intensive care surgery and
imaging will still remain at the
hospitals at least I believe for the
foreseeable future few weeks ago I met a
colleague whose mom was diagnosed with
incurable cancer and she said Niels it's
hard it's so hard well we know that
she's got only months to live
instead of playing where the
grandchildren she now has to travel
three times a week two hours up and down
to Amsterdam just to gather treatment
and tests and that really breaks my
heart because we all know that a
professional nurse could draw her blood
at home as well right
and if she could get her tests and
treatment than home as well she could do
the things that are really important to
her in her last month my own mom 82 year
now so god bless her she's avoiding to
go to the hospital because she finds it
difficult to plan and manage the journey
so my sisters and I would help her out
but there's many elderly people who were
avoiding care and awaiting that long
that it becomes life-threatening and
it's straight to the costly intensive
care doctor covin see a clinical
researcher at the University of
California he concludes that 1/3 of
patients over 70 and more than half of
patients over 85 leave the hospital more
disabled than when they came in and a
very practical problem that many
patients face when they have to go to a
hospital is where do I go with my main
companion in life where do I go with my
dog that's our dog by the way isn't she
cute but it's not only about convenience
it's also about unnecessary health care
stays and cost a friend of mine art he
recently need to be hospitalized for
just some minor surgery and he had to
stay in a hospital for over two weeks
just because he needed a specific kind
of IV antibiotics so he occupied the bed
for two weeks that cost over a thousand
euros a day it's just ridiculous and
these costs are really at the heart of
the issue so we've seen in many of our
global economies health care expense
grow as a percentage of GDP over the
last year's so here we see that of the
last 50 years healthcare expense has
grown from about 5% in Germany to about
11% now in the u.s. we've seen growth
from 6% to over 17% now and a large
portion of these cost are driven by
investments in large shiny hospital
buildings and these buildings are not
flexible and they maintain a system
where hospital beds need to be filled
for a hospital to run efficiently
there's no incentive for a hospital to
run with less beds just the thought of
that makes you sick right and here's the
thing
the cost for treating my buddy art at
home can be up to 10 times cheaper than
hospital care and that is where we're
headed the hospital bed of the future
will be in our own homes and so ready
starting global home care is grown ten
percent year-over-year and from my own
experience I see that logistics and
technology are making these home
healthcare solutions work technology is
already allowing us to do things that
were once exclusive to hospitals
diagnosis tests like blood glucose tests
urine tests can now be taken at the
comfort of our homes and more more
connected devices we see like pacemakers
and insulin pumps that will proactively
signal if help is needed soon and all
that technology is coming together a
much more insights into the patient's
health and that insights and all that
information leads to better control and
to less medical errors remember the
third cause of death in the u.s. and I
see it every day at work I work in
logistics and for me home healthcare
works so we see a delivery driver
deliver the medicine to the patient's
home a nurse joins in and actually
administers the drug at the patient's
home right it's that simple
remember my buddy art he can now get the
IV antibiotics at the comfort of his
home now hospital
no crappy food and no risk of these
antibiotic resistant superbugs that only
bite you in these hospitals and it goes
further so now the elderly people can
get the treatment that they need in a
comfort of their own home while with
their best companion in life and there's
no need anymore
for to drive hours and hours just to get
your treatment and tests in the
Netherlands and in Denmark we've seen
very good successes in cancer clinics
organizing chemo therapies at the
patients homes sometimes even together
with fellow patients the best
improvements for these patients have
been improvements in reduction in stress
anxiety disorders and depression
home health care also helped them to get
back a sense of normality and freedom in
their lives and they've actually helped
them to forget about their disease but
home health care bills whatever what if
I don't even have a home
when I'm homeless or when I do have a
home but there's no one to take care of
me or even open up the door
well incomes are sharing economy or as I
like to call it the air B&B for home
care in the Nellis we see churches and
care organizations match people in need
of caring company with people who
actually have a home for them and can
provide care and company to them home
health care is cheaper is easier to
facilitate and it's quick to set up in
these rural areas we talked about but
also in humanitarian crisis situations
where it's often safer quicker and
cheaper to set things up at home home
health care is very applicable in
prosperous areas but also very much in
underserved communities home health care
works in developed countries as well as
in developing countries so I'm
passionate to help facilitate
improvements in patients lives due to
home health care I'm passionate to help
facilitate that the elderly people
the treatment that they need in the
comfort of their own homes together with
their best companion in life I'm
passionate to make the change and help
ensure that patients and not their
disease are in control of their lives to
me that is healthcare delivered at home
thank you
[Applause]